if no one's seen the video of the zombie  ants or a fungus literally makes this  ant ignore all of its Instinct in his  training climbed to a top of a leaf  attached to a certain kind of leaf on a  certain Tree on a certain side of the  tree and then die and then fall to the  ground so that the fungus can replicate  in the ant's body just screw it up it is  but that's the power that fungi can have  over seemingly sentient beings and make  you literally become a zombie I think  that's absolutely a thing and I think  that's something that our researchers at  The Hobbit School of Public Health they  need to start looking into that kind of  stuff